hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Google feud now it's
been a few years since I played this
last so I can only assume that I'm too
old and senile they actually get
whatever the hip happenin kids are
looking for on the Internet these days
or I can approach it with my normal
egomania and just assume that I'm right
all the time and everyone else is an
idiot so I'm gonna go with that route
and not go with the old senile route and
I'm just gonna plow forward as fast as I
can let's start with culture I think my
mom isn't here I think my mom is from
Mars I think that my mom is a man oh
[ __ ] sorry mom Joshua heck Joshua Jones
Joshua Joshua put his penis in the salsa
stop putting your dick in the salsa
Stephen stop stop eating my burrito
Steven take your dog out of my Stephen
Colbert okay all right beef jerky is
beef jerky beef jerky is jerk is it
weird to like having nails shoved in my
eyes is it weird to like penis is it
weird to like taking my ass for Ryan
Gosling
Ryan goose lling Ryan dude I drank too
much semen I drank too many papers too
much beaver how to make a sandwich how
to make a man out of you
how to make a woman out of me how to
kill
mockingbirds hora how to kill a bear
with your bare hands how to kill a shark
with your shark hands how to kill a
beaver with your beaver how to look your
best how to look good how to look pretty
cute fat handsome I hate it when you
call me out for murder I hate it when
you don't smash that like button oh I
hate it when you offer me a burrito and
it's just your dick in a tortilla
wrestling is is one step away from
insertion I want to be a rock star I
want to be a millionaire a billionaire
is it painful to squeeze a baby through
your peepee is it cool to wear
sunglasses is it cool to wear a human
wearing sunglasses mm-hmm is it healthy
to eat but is it healthy to eat ass is
it Elfi to eat is my Bertil I build the
Washington Monument why did they build
the stairway to heaven why did they
build this big all just dick in my
living room what they do it oh it's a
nice art piece I suppose but it's just
constant at me is duct tape safe for
this is duct tape safe for keeping the
poopy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
boy all right
strapping mice to my bottle rocket
that's not a euphemism is duct tape save
for ducts mmm where can you sell a bunch
of Girl Scout cookies
no questions asked
do babies like being tossed like
football do babies like being kicked
through what happens when you mix
alcohol and even more alcohol what what
happens when you mix alcohol and a man
dangerously close to explosive pop a
central
[Music]
is it wrong to make boom-boom is it
wrong to hold hands in public is it
wrong the true composed to the fake
capacity or just what we're all taught
to believe what body birds can you live
without what body parts can you replace
with robots what body parts can you fit
in the freezer why am I afraid of the
man I'm sorry is it bad to mix is it bad
to mix it grandpa's ashes with my tank
is it bad to hide an attack beaver just
to surprise the mailman what happened to
markiplier
what just what the hell happened what is
worse than using fingernail clippings to
add some crunch
what is worse than whispers and sneezing
into the Cask jacket Magnum condoms for
my Magnum Tom does Canada have
people does Canada have the technology
the technology to weaponize beavers you
know for my mailbox attack paper I need
to know who does Canada have nukes [ __ ]
why does my arm my arm constantly point
towards how long should I keep my how
long should I
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey Doc I got another question for you I
know you really liked the last one how
long how long do you think I should keep
the poopy up and should I replace the
duct tape is what I'm asking you okay
okay all right I think that's gonna have
to do it I
yeah I'm pretty dumb I uh I'm pretty
dumb I don't know why this is duct tape
safe to keep don't know why that makes
me laugh why the Frick it's just like
saying thinking that sentence doesn't
make me laugh saying that sentence makes
me laugh for some reason I can think and
that's fine but if I say is duct tape
safe to keep the poopy I don't know all
right whatever so I'm done here that was
Google feud I'll probably play it again
in another year or so but thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play google food go to google
feud comma put a link in the description
below and let me know what you thought
if you thought any of my answers were
more stupid than the others right your
favorite stupid answer in the comments
down below and if you have some stupid
answers as well write them down there as
well thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye